mentoring is described in the literature
as an essential component to career
success productivity and satisfaction
hello and welcome everyone to today's
workshop on project-based bioinformatics
and data science training for faculty
and mentors
this workshop is for faculty seeking to
examine share and strengthen their own
mentoring practices
faculty will learn evidence-based
approaches to research and conceptual
and practical knowledge about various
specialization tracks which include
precision medicine infectious diseases
neurosciences oncology space omics
agriculture and ai based drug discovery
so before we begin with today's workshop
let me introduce us
we are a us based bioinformatics company
who is working with multiple academic
and commercial collaborators to develop
easy to use analytical tools and our
mission is to make bioinformatics more
accessible
the training has been completed by over
15 000 participants from 162 countries
in over 300 workshops and due to this
fast growth our team is working with
local and regional coordinators that are
helping refine the local program
logistics and leverage our online
training resources adapting them to the
needs of students and researchers around
the world
i am honored to introduce the founders
and team members of the company
dr alfred tauber comes from a medical
background with an expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
information and one of his major
projects is the establishment of
troubled bioinformatics research center
which has been at the core of what we do
dr lloyd brodsky is the director of
tobal bioinformatics research center and
is an expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics
our platform is a result of hard work by
some of the people mentioned here on the
right julia panna is an expert
bioinformatician avi tatovsky leads the
development of t bioinfo platform dr
mohit mazumdar is an experienced
bioinformatician with multiple
publications in peer-reviewed journal he
has been developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omixlogic training and research
fellowship
dr raghavendra lakshmi narayanan is an
accomplished computational biologist
with an expertise in large scale
analysis of multi or mixed data and data
science methods in precision oncology
and protein dna structural
bioinformatics
ms laura murray educational program
coordinator has a background in
microbiology and bioinformatics and her
focus and areas of expertise are in
metagenomics transcriptomics and
genomics
and my name is sunalika ray and i am the
community manager responsible for daily
interaction with thousands of users that
are a part of a bioinformatics community
which is managed by buying biotech
so let's discuss about bioinformatics
today what is bioinformatics it is the
development implementation and usage of
methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical
applications in healthcare agriculture
and mitigating climate change
as this field progresses bioinformatics
poses several challenges for both
students trying to learn it and faculty
trying to teach it
in this presentation i will explain the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics describing how we aim to
address these challenges with the
omixlogic platform describe bloom's
taxonomy and how it can be used in
bioinformatics course work and explore
the omixlogic program and how it
utilizes bloom's taxonomy in structuring
its course pipelines and projects and
finally describes several outcomes of
the omixlogic program
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are
usually very large and take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have in a
university setting students have the
opportunity to learn the background
information of designing and
implementing a bioinformatics project
but do not receive practical hands-on
experience with the full workflow due to
the limitations mentioned previously
similarly the culture faces challenges
with being able to cover a diverse range
of topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general
for example a professor whose research
focuses on oncogene expression might not
know much about metagenomics of sea
water
to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic platform was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
some problems for standardization
materials for these courses are usually
developed in-house taught sporadically
and are rarely updated
organization because the challenge is to
be is to combine several different
topics together the flow and transitions
are needed to be developed
systemization how can you know that
someone is stuck and needs help or allow
someone to run forward
omixlogic uses standardized modules and
interactive sessions beginning with
mastering terminology and concepts to
implementing these concepts with real
data sets in a project based approach
learning process in order to create a
clear path of skill development
omixlogic employs the bloom's taxonomy
levels of learning this approach starts
with the basics students recall facts
and terminology and are able to repeat
and memorize the material with this
space the learning builds to conceptual
knowledge being able to understand
concepts and apply information to new
situations
the student will then be able to analyze
data by drawing connections and evaluate
when to use certain methods this leads
them to the highest level of learning
the ability to design and create
original work
so how do omix logic resources help in
advancing bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge
omixlogic takes a combination of
training modules data analysis tools
curated project data sets and
interactive sessions with mentors to
give a student a clear path the bloom's
taxonomy pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is
omixlogic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large
datasets and introduction to basic
coding languages like r and python are
beginning a data analysis project
these six courses were taken from the
core of mixed logic curriculum which is
available online
beginning with an introduction to the
application of bioinformatics and an
overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon
from there genomics transcriptomics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science are introduced
each course starts with important terms
and concepts and then introduces case
studies and pipelines related to each
one this allows the students to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
expanding basic curriculum with projects
bioinformatics methods are best learned
in the context of real case studies
which are prepared by our network of
mentors and collaborators that
illustrate how various bioinformatics
methods and omix data types are used in
current research in medicine
biotechnology agriculture and even
astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available data sets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis path
to extract meaningful insights from
complex comics data
the omixlogic platform gives students
options for analyzing a given data set
these datasets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all for that in each project
we explain the analysis pipelines on the
user-friendly t by info platform for big
data analysis you can also learn the
scripts behind many of the steps
learning to wrangle clean visualize and
analyze data in popular languages like r
and python in order to create your own
analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline
the pipeline builder interface on the t
bioinfo platform is a color coded
pipeline that helps establish a logical
connection between the technical names
of data analysis methods and the logical
steps needed to build the full pipeline
data is put in an input file and then
the analysis can be chosen based off of
the type of research
each analysis is separated into three
colors
blue for pre-processing red for mapping
and green for quantification
each time you click a button a pop-up
will contain additional information
useful for building the pipeline the
ease of the color-coded buttons allows
programs to be run without any coding
knowledge
after using the t-bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge
remember and understand levels of dooms
and apply that in a project apply
analyze and evaluate levels of groups
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the omixlogic program to their
students with the understanding that it
will give them holistic and
comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
another goal of the project is for
students to be able to read primary
literature and understand and recreate
the methodology
this leads to the ability to encounter
errors apply theoretical knowledge of
why those errors are occurring and find
a solution
omixlogic employs the hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first level of bloom's taxonomy
omixlogic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews
quizzes on topics k terms and important
questions and covers a broad range of
topics like biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
then students are able to continue their
knowledge base with the research
assessment
making sure they are able to understand
methods challenges and results as well
as being able to comprehend primary
research literature
they should also be able to ask
questions based on data exploration
bioinformatics combines life science
terms with data science skills which
allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis
methods mixed logic research fellows are
able to ask research questions about any
bioinformatics topic leading to a
diverse range of projects from analyzing
affected biological pathways in multiple
sclerosis to brain metastasis due to
small cell lung cancer these students
are able to apply what they have learned
in the coursework work with a group of
professional mentors and submit their
projects on the portal for review
students should then be able to reach
the highest level of bloom's taxonomy
create this is achieved through the
creation of their own analysis project
for example semi-dolina an undergraduate
researcher at bachelor university
istanbul turkey who finished her
omixlogic research training was able to
work on the project involving chronic
lymphocytic leukemia cll a type of blood
cancer that has a very heterogeneous
biological background and diverse
treatment strategies here at first she
elucidated 870 significantly
differentially expressed protein coding
genes that were involved in the
biogenesis and processing of rna
consequently these findings led our
study to investigate non-coding rna
33 long non-coding rnas were found to be
significantly differentially expressed
among two conditions based on
differential gene expression analysis
one final example of a learning outcome
of the omixlogic program
is this project presentation for a
project done in collaboration between
nagochi memorial institute
for medical research and pain biotech
here is our team at pine biotech who
were involved with the project dr mohit
mazumdak dr harpreet kaur as well as our
collaborators at university of khanna dr
anita gansha and dr benedict tamensa
this poster was on plasmodium falciparum
optical membrane antigen
robbery neck protein 2 binding which is
a critical interaction for plasmodium
falciparum mineral invasion of human
host red blood cells several proposed
malaria vaccine candidates designed to
prevent such binding and limit meteoroid
entry have been studied with variable
success at in-vitro and early clinical
trial stages by performing haplotype
network analysis of genomic sequencing
data from sites with variable infection
rates comparing our data with malaria
gen repository from another region in
ghana and mapping of genomic variants
onto the protein structures we arrive at
preliminary conclusions about local
variation and immunogenic epitope
effecting variance for consideration
in this poster we share preliminary
findings that suggest that such genomic
data can be used to develop a local
strategy for efficacious vaccine design
against plasmodium falciparum blood
stage inspection in ghana and
surrounding regions
omixlogic is proud to collaborate with
diverse programs for example nepi the
national association of idea principal
investigators we also work with over 15
000 students at community colleges like
glendale community college top-tier
universities like georgetown university
as well as 20 universities around the
world now to talk about the programs in